chin hello hi I'm a doctor Anthony
mirada chief scientific officer from our
X life sciences corp and today i'll be
presenting data on soluble 14 23 atta
focusing on a personalized rheumatoid
arthritis patient management strategy
these are my disclosures and these are
the learning objectives for the
particular presentation that i'll be
giving today so one of the first things
that i think is important as a learning
objective is to describe how 14 23 ada
specifically in the context of RA
differs from the other 14 to three
isoforms as part of the the learning
objective will also look at three
different ways in which 14 33 ada
informs clinical management of RA we'll
talk a little bit about the for
biomarkers that have resulted as a
consequence of our rd efforts and then
we'll explain or you know looked at why
14 23 represents a rational drug target
before i get into the presentation i
think it's important to delineate how r
ex came to fruition as a scientist
working in the reagent space we realized
that there were a lot of early stage
technologies at the level of the
university that looked very promising
but really didn't have the robustness
around the data to be to garnered to
support our attention of the large
diagnostic companies to one of the
things that we elected to do was to
really create a company that would
fulfill that gap where would take these
early stage promising technologies
fulfill the middle piece by you know
really working with key opinion leaders
to understand not only the unmet needs
but to advance the marker along those
lines all of which you know to get to
the point
to these markers would look attractive
to the larger commercial diagnostic
partners and what's nice is that we
fulfilled this model working with us
partners and we're currently working on
advancing our marker in the rest of
world so we've recently obtained Health
Canada approval European approval and so
now it's nice to be at a point that you
know the marker can actually be
commercialized in used clinically so our
founding technology is the 1433 ADA
protein and this discovery actually came
about through the University of British
Columbia as well as the University of
Alberta there was a scientist working in
the area of skin and wound healing and
he made an interesting observation that
14 3 3 sigma one of the other isoforms
14 to three isoforms was actually
released in derma file through dermal
fibroblasts and when it was released
dude dermal fibroblasts it would feed
back on to the cells stimulating them to
produce mmp-1 now nra one of the major
issues is the synovial fibroblasts they
actually become very active and they
form what he would consider a non
malignant growth almost like a tumor and
these fibroblasts are intimately linked
to joint degradation and so with that
one of the things that the second
discover who's a Rheumatologist
initiated was well I hit 1433 Sigma in
the context of skin and wound healing is
playing a role in the induction of MPs I
wonder if any of the other 14 to three
isoforms play a role in the context of
RA and could you know contribute to the
joint damage process since M MPs are
linked to joint degradation so with that
the two investigators the basic
scientists in the rheumatologist decided
that they would screen synovial fluid
and serum from patients with
inflammatory arthritis to look to see if
any of the 14 to three isoforms were
relevant
and so what they did so SF on the figure
here represents synovial fluid p.s is
matched patient serum and k is a cell
life state it's a character inside cell
lysate so based on you know the
profiling of the different 14-3 family
members what they saw was at 14 23 ada
as well as gamma were detectable in both
synovial fluid and matched patient serum
and that the levels of the markers so
the 14 3 and n gamma were significantly
higher in patients with inflammatory
arthritis then in corresponding healthy
controls they also observed and reported
in a paper that the levels the 14 23
love ada levels were five times higher
and synovial fluid than in match patient
serum and incidentally one of the other
observations was that 14 23 ADA was
significantly higher than 14 23 gamma so
through this it was based on this
technology that we essentially licensed
and 14 23 8 and spent the last five
years advancing it to the point that
it's clinically ready so before we get
into some of the clinical data I think
it's important to understand what the 14
to three proteins are and why 14 to 38
is still relevant in the context of RA
now the 14 three proteins they've been
discovered approximately 50 years ago
there's a lot of interest obviously in
terms of their intracellular function
they behave as molecular chaperones
regulating an array of biological
processes they were initially discovered
as brain proteins and there's evidence
that in the context of certain
neurological disorders that other 14 to
three isoforms have utility as a
diagnostic marker so for instance for 14
23 ADA is used to diagnose fruits failed
jakub now they were coined as being or
are named as being 14 to three proteins
based on how they eluded during
purification there are seven different
tough family members sharing
approximately fifty percent of me know
etymology and the relevant isoform nra
based on the initial discovery as well
as all of our data is 14 3380 so from
this point forward I'm going to focus on
14 23 ADA I should mention to both I
apologize for this that if you have any
questions please feel free to send
through your questions and I will
address those at the end of the the talk
now the 1433 ADA protein itself maps to
chromosome 22 its size is 246 amino
acids in length giving it a molecular
weight of approximately 28 killa domes
and when you look at 14 33 ada across
different species it's highly conserved
so when we look at the human mouse and
rat there's only two amino acid
differences which are denoted on the
slide in red so they're highly
homologous now when we look at the 14-3
protein more structurally it's a small
acidic protein it consists of 9 alpha
helixes and it has a variable carboxyl
and terminal end when they come together
14 to three proteins as a whole can
either homodimer eyes so they bind to
one another or they can heterodimer eyes
and through that dimerization process
you can see on the image on this
particular slide that they form an amp
the amphipathic groove which allows them
to bind with various ligands now a lot
of the data shows that 1433 proteins as
a whole bind two distinct phosphopeptide
moieties but there is recent evidence as
well that the 14 to three proteins can
bind to other particular sites that are
independent of phosphorylation hence
they don't require phosphorylation so
it's through you know these fossil and
non-fossil binding motifs that 14 23 is
able to interact with various ligands
and to date there's over 200 ligands
that the fork into three proteins bind
to and 44
23 de there's approximately 150 now when
we look back to 14 23 ada and ra one of
the other things that the investigators
realized through their efforts was that
when they looked at fourteen 238 and
related it to mmp-1 expression they
found that there was us very strong
correlation between levels of 14 33 ada
in synovial fluid and serum with that of
mmp-1 and em mp3 so if you look the
correlation between 14 23 Ada and mmp-1
was point 83 and with em mp3 its point
77 and that correlation held true and
very significant also in serum so was
with this that the investigators thought
that 14 23 ADA might actually contribute
to the joint damage process by
upregulating mmp-1 and mp3 so as part of
that the investigators also perform
stimulation studies and what they found
was that 14 23 had soluble lion-like
properties and was capable of inducing
factors like mmp-1 so again it was
really very much with this preliminary
data that we decided to license 1433 am
from the University and really advanced
it now when you look at RA it's not
unlike cancer it's very important to
find patients early to know who's at
risk of developing more aggressive
disease and to have markers that can
inform therapeutic outcomes the other
aspect that is becoming more and more
relevant is screening individuals to
identify patients who are at high risk
of developing the disease so it was very
much with this that we started to work
on fourteenth degree with the opinion
leaders to investigate along which of
these particular tracks would 14 23
offer clinical utility so I'll focus
initially on diagnosis and
show you some of the preliminary data
around why 14 23 is useful as a
diagnostic marker so to date we've
looked at north of a thousand samples
and specifically in our a over four
hundred samples and what we consistently
see through our studies is that 14 23
aids in diagnosing re so complement
current variables in identifying more
patients which is very very important to
clinicians before we get into the data I
think it's important to look at how ra
is classified based on you learn ACR
correct classification criteria so
you'll r is the european league against
rheumatism and ACR is american college
of rheumatology so they have joint
meetings together the europe the
european key opinion leaders as well as
the American opinion leaders and they
come together to develop these
classification criteria and I think
what's interesting the last time that
these criteria were revised prior to
2010 was in 1987 so there was a long
hiatus between you know 1997 and 2010
and really I think some of the pressures
that drove the 2010 classification
criteria was that the field was moving
or evolving at a very fast rate and it
was with that that they also
incorporated additional markers into the
classification criteria so today forty
percent of the total classification
score is based on serological markers
like see CRP ESR so CRP c-reactive
protein ESR is the urethra site
sedimentation rate and then two other
markers that are commonly used to
classify the disease rrf so rheumatoid
factor and akpa which has really
recently been being renamed and that
stands for anti sit related cichlid or
so anti cyclic sit related protein which
is the form of a post-translational
modifications of the body mounts
an immune response to these citroen
elated moieties and so rfn akpa are
quite commonly used to diagnose sorry
CRP and ESR use more firm monitoring and
looking at disease activity I think
what's really interesting is if you look
at what's noted on the right hand side
of the slide approximately forty percent
of RA patients have normal serological
measurements so there's a realignment
need to have additional markers that can
complement the current variables to
identify more patients and to also
assist with monitoring you know their
diseases and as we go through the
presentation you'll see why it's so
important to also have markers that chin
monitor disease severity and prognosis
so the field you know as I was saying
recognizes that there's a real
importance in early diagnosis not unlike
cancer when you identify or catch a
patient very early on it equates with
better outcomes so they refer to it in
the field of rheumatology as the
therapeutic window so the field says
that if you catch a patient within the
first 12 weeks there's a better
likelihood that the patient will do
better you know five years out and so
really you know what clinicians are
trying to do is to identify the
patient's much earlier on identify who's
at risk of aggressive disease so that
they can treat them more aggressively so
it was very much with that that we
started to look at 14 33 ada in the
context of RA as a diagnostic marker so
we used established re which represents
the 135 patients to identify or to
establish our cutoff for 14 23
positivity and so we've looked at
various controls that are typically used
for a fda 510 k submission or for ze
marking or Health Canada approval and so
as you can see from the data on the left
hand side where we're looking at 135 RA
patients compared to the controls
the marker is significantly higher in ra
compared to all other controls and when
you run a ROC curve which is presented
on the right-hand side so a rocker was
the receiver operating characteristic
curve that allows us to identify the
most optimal cut off looking at
sensitivity and specificity in my
pursuit with the specificity of the
marker you know how specific is that
marker for RA and the sensitivity is
obviously how many RA patients do you
capture and so typically speaking when
you establish you know the optimal cut
off you want to look at the likelihood
ratios for positivity so we elected to
go with a likelihood ratio of five as
our cutoff based on the advice that the
opinion leaders provided to us and so
looking at RA in comparing it to the
controls we realized that the more the
data showed is pardon me that the best
cut off was point 19 nanograms per mil
so if you have levels of 0.19 nanograms
per mil your five times more likely to
have RA than any other disease so the
scale on the left hand side is 14 to
three serum levels and it's represented
as nanogram per mil I apologize that the
descriptor was deleted from from the
slide but just know that the data there
the range 0 to 20 is the 1433
concentration and it's represented as
nanograms per mil now when we move over
to the right-hand image of the scattered
dot plot we looked at earlier a versus
away so many times when a patient enters
primary care the clinician may have some
difficulty distinguishing between OA
osteoarthritis versus early re because
many of the symptoms are very similar so
we elected to start looking at 14 23 ADA
in our earlier array and comparing it to
OA as the corresponding disease control
and what we saw in early ra in the first
thirty seven patients
we looked at was that 14 23 it is
significantly higher in early re than
noe so this marker holds promises are
promises pardon me in assisting
clinicians in differentiating between OA
versus earlier which is obviously very
important because if you can catch the
patient very early on in primary care
and refer them to a Rheumatologist early
on then you have a better chance of
impacting patient outcomes and so using
the point 19 cutoff we've identified
that approximately sixty percent of all
early ra patients are positive for 14 23
and we have data now in over 250 early
ra patients that whole shows that 14 23
is a useful diagnostic tool and
compliments current variables so i think
based on this data you know we believe
that 14 23 will hold promise in
assisting and complementing current
variables to identify more patients
earlier on so one of the questions that
we received was is 14 23 ada when it
exists in the serum is it there as a
bystander of disease or does it possibly
contribute to the joint damage process
and so knowing what the serum levels of
14 33 were in re we decided to
investigate the mechanism of action for
14 through three so we used for all of
our studies clinically relevant
concentrations to perform cell-based
stimulations and so we've looked at
immortalized cell lines we've looked at
primary cells from healthy donors of
pbmc s and we consistently see that 14th
3 is able to induce various factors that
contribute to the drink damage process
and now when we look at the in vitro
data and compare it to the clinical data
we see that there is a very strong
correlation between the in vitro
findings and the clinical findings
providing strong evidence at 14 23 is a
new target and
it warrants further efforts to try to
develop a small molecule or putting a
large molecule to this particular entity
so this is some of the preliminary
results that we haven't in the interest
of time I haven't had the opportunity to
present everything but we've looked at
various intracellular signaling factors
that are relevant NRA and so what we're
presenting here is data on map kinase so
the pathway and one of the reasons why
we elected to look at the erk pathway
was that Birk or map kinase has been
shown to be upregulated in the synovium
of patients with RA very early on so
there's evidence in the literature that
shows that both work and junk seem to be
active in early disease and not p38
there's also evidence that when you
target or use inhibitors to mequon which
is the upstream activator of earth that
you can actually block or inhibit the
onset of the disease it using animal
models so there's two animal models and
in particular for us the CIA model is
very relevant that the collagen-induced
arthritis model of arthritis so when you
look at the data that's presented here
one of the things that we wanted to do
was do head-to-head studies looking at
14 23 verses TNF as a soluble ligand and
using similar concentrations we found
that a time-dependent manner 1433 ADA
was able to activate or induce the
phosphorylation of both Mac as well as
herb so if you look at the data here you
can see by five minutes that stimulation
with 1433 leads to an induction or
increased phosphorylation of erk as well
as Mac when you compared to the
corresponding control sample
and if you look at TNF as well comparing
again be controlled to the stimulated
you can see that by five and ten minutes
respectively that Tina's alpha is also
able to induce the phosphorylation of
both makan arc which equate with
activation of these particular targets
and the bottom panel there the pan earth
is just represented to show that equal
amounts of protein have been loaded
across all conditions so we've looked
now at north of 30 different
intracellular kindnesses and we've been
able to you know observe that 1433
exhibit some similarities to tnf-alpha
in terms of the pathways that are
activated but there are distinct
features as well so for instance TNF
alpha is known to be a potent stimulator
both p38 map kinase as an NF Kappa B the
data that we have shows that 14 23
actually does not hit these particular
targets so we don't see activation of
p30 or NF Kappa B when cells are
stimulated with 14 23 so we think that
because of this because there's some
discreteness in terms of how 14-3
signals in that again when we're
thinking of targeting 14 23 with a large
molecule that they're obviously will be
different outcomes as a consequence of
the intracellular factors that they
stimulate one of the next things that we
elected to do was to look at okay you
have all these signals coming into the
cell now do the activation of these
pathways culminate or lead to the
induction of factors that are relevant
in the joint damage process and so when
we again did head-to-head studies
looking at 14 23 verses tnf-alpha we saw
that again comparing it to control on
the left hand side we saw that both 14-3
and tnf-alpha could induce factors that
are relevant
to re so we saw an induction of il-1
beta aisle 8 mcp-1 nip one tnf-alpha and
again this is limited data we've
explored this and you know greater
context and we see that 14-3 can induce
various factors that are intimately
linked to the drink damage or the are a
physiologic or pathologic process pardon
me so I l1 there's actually a drug on
the market that targets that there are
drugs under investigation for mcp-1 and
as I'm sure you can appreciate the anti
TNF need no introduction in terms of
their utility in in the field of RA
there's I think today over five
different molecules that specific
biological molecules that target
tnf-alpha are used essentially almost
first or second line in terms of
treating patients with RA so based on
all the data that we have around the
mechanism of action for 14 through three
this is what we believe the mechanism is
for 14 23 when I do exist extracellular
Lee NRI so on the left-hand slide just
to remind you the 14 three proteins and
specifically in our a 14-3 380 exists
intracellularly so if we look at this
image on the left hand side the gray bar
represents the cell membrane so under
normal circumstances 14 238 it would
exist intracellularly and when at home
hetero or homo dimerizes it binds to
various lines as I've noted in the
earlier slides of the presentation and
through those interactions 1433 is able
to regulate a variety of different tough
physiologic processes ranging from cell
cycle angiogenesis differentiation and I
think one of the things that's of
interest just as well is that 14 23
binds to the glucocorticoid receptor now
your body produces glucocorticoids which
essentially are steroids that
when they come into the cell they would
elicit an anti-inflammatory effect the
glucocorticoid receptor needs 14-3 to be
stabilized if there's not an interaction
between the glucocorticoid receptor in
1433 the glucocorticoid receptor is sent
to the proteasome where it is
essentially you've accumulated and
subsequently degradation when 1433
interacts with the glucocorticoid
receptor it stabilizes it preventing it
from being you've accumulated allowing
it to bind to endogenous steroid move
into the cell membrane and to elicit an
anti-inflammatory effect so on the
inside of the cell it appears that 14 23
exists and assists in eliciting an
anti-inflammatory effect and
incidentally there are also when you
look at the 14 38 a promoter there are
gr response elements within the actual
promoter 14 23 so there is a direct link
there and a regulation of 14 23 when
glucocorticoids essential bind to the
glucocorticoid receptor now if we move
over to the right-hand side of the image
nra 14 23 which normally exist
intracellularly is released into the
synovial fluid within the joint and we
believe that that's occurring by one of
two mechanisms it's either being
secreted directly or is being released
through exosomes so 14 23 ada and
specifically the other 14 to three
isoforms are known to be quite commonly
present within exosomes now when 14 33
exists six extracellular Lee as I've
said you know we've investigated a lot
of the mechanism of action for 14 23
using clinically relevant concentrations
we see their 14th III is able to induce
members of various members of the map
kinase family so herb and junk it also
induces a kt which provides an
antiapoptotic signal interestingly it
also activates the jak-stat pathway
which is a very important inflammatory
driver
and there's it also activates specific
isoforms of the pkc family members of
protein kinase c and based on this those
signals culminate as i said at the level
of the nucleus to induce factors that
drive both inflammation and joint damage
so when we look at the clinical data
knowing what the mechanism of action is
for 14-3 one of the things that we've
looked at is if 14-3 is driving joint
damage factors then we would expect that
patients who have more 14 23 would have
more joint damage we would also expect
that if you have lower levels of 14 33
you might do better clinically on
certain classes of therapy than if you
have higher levels of 14 23 so a lot of
our additional studies have focused on
looking at the relevance of 14 23 in
relation to ship to joint damage and
with response to therapy now when we
embarked on this program the initial
biomarker as you know was 14 2380
because 14 338 exists intracellularly
under normal circumstances one of the
questions that arose was well is 14 3
scene 14 23 a department seen as being
foreign and does the body mount an
immune response to the protein in an
effort to Clara that was one of the
first questions that we received one of
the additional questions was because
citroen relation is such an active
process in re and because many of these
enzymes that are involved in citroen
late in proteins exist exercise early is
14 23 also a citroen elation target so
we've now spent efforts looking at Auto
antibodies to 14 23 as well as looking
at whether or not 14 33 is it related
and so when we look at 14 33 initially
licensing in a single technology this is
morphed into five separate technologies
and it's created a personalized medicine
portfolio for our XO on the upper left
tan quadrant we have 14 338 of the
protein which I've been talking about
thus far as I said in our eight there's
these enzymes called peptidyl arginine
demonizes which citroen late various
proteins and the body actually mounts an
immune response to these it related
proteins and hence you can measure you
know these anti citroen cyclic sit
related antibodies which are used
diagnostically and so there we've seen
that 14 23 is now sit related we also
have seen that as you move down to the
lower hand portion of the slide on the
Left we've seen that there's specific
Auto antibodies that are raised to the
protein but there are also auto
antibodies that are there that recognize
thus it related form of 1433 so there's
four different biomarkers now that we're
currently advancing the 14 23 protein
the citroen related 1433 protein and the
two corresponding Auto antibodies and
through our mechanism of action studies
we also believe that 14 3 represents a
new therapeutic target and so that's the
fifth technology that we're currently
advancing in the field I'm going to
present data today a little bit on the
fourteenth two three auto antibodies the
image on the lower left hand side of the
slide here and we're currently advancing
the to sit related asses and actually
we're just finishing up some studies
right now looking at the citroen later
Auto antibodies and how they complement
current variables as well as the 214
three markers live 14 23 protein marker
and the 14 23 auto antibodies and the
data looks very exciting so I look
forward to the opportunity to share more
of that data with you so when we think
of the 14 23 biomarkers in the clinical
applications when we first started off
we were talking about the 14 23 protein
and looking along screening diagnosis
prognosis and therapy monitoring we are
now
King at all four markers along the this
particular continuum and the reason why
14 23 ADA is highlighted in gray or a
darker shade of grey is that this test
is now commercially available in the US
and as I was saying when we started off
on the call it's also received European
approval and Health Canada approval and
we're just currently working to with
distributors to look at how we're going
to commercialize the particular test in
and rest the world so one of the things
now that you know I'll move forward with
is looking at you know 14 23 in terms of
prognosis therapy monitoring and I'll
just present some preliminary data on
the ante for 23 Auto antibodies what's
interesting is that when we look at the
two markers on the left hand side the 14
23 80 and 90 14-3 traitor we see that
they're very complementary to one
another and that they can be used to
stratify patients and identify a higher
risk patients so so moving along one of
the things that we've elected to do was
look at how 14-3 tracks with disease
severity and if it equates with worse
outcomes so so what we've seen is that
14-3 positivity and titers so if you're
positive for 14 to three and if you have
certain levels that corresponds with
more severe disease a higher likelihood
of joint damage and during damage
progression and we've seen this now in
north of 300 patients consistently so we
think that that holds promise in terms
of assisting clinicians not only in
terms of diagnosing patients early on
but also assisting in stratification and
identifying patients who are at more
risk for developing more severe disease
so why is identifying patients with high
risk obviously important well if you
identify subset of patients that are
more at risk you would arguably treat
them more aggressively hoping to
mitigate disease progression now when we
look at the current variables that
clinicians have you can see if the pie
chart there represents the total amount
of joint damage or predicting joint
damage you can see that the current
markers that collections have while
they're useful they don't predict a lot
of the variants associated with joint
damage so in fact when you look at it it
predicts the current variables predict
about thirty two percent of the total
variation of joint damage so sixty-eight
percent of joint damage progression is
unexplained by the current markers so
there's a real need to have
complementary markers that can really
assist augment the current markers and
assist clinicians in identifying
patients who are at more risk of
developing alright and so this is
actually a really significant effort
within the field of rheumatology and
there's a group called almerac iraq from
me that was established to identify
markers that can complement the current
variables and fill that 68% gap in right
now they're conducting a study called
bio dam which is to identify biomarkers
of damage in the 14 23 biomarker suite
or panel has been prioritized by the
investigators to be to be looked at in
this particular formal construct to see
if the data that we currently have will
hold true in a larger study so they're
recruiting over 600 patients really with
the view of identifying markers that can
assist in terms of identifying patients
at baseline who are more risk but also
in terms of the continuum of how
patients are treated they believed that
the change in the marker should reflect
the change in
Peter gal or I mean in patient outcomes
as well so as you can see you know to
summarize from the slide there's a need
for complementary markers that can
assist clinicians in stratifying
patients who are more at risk of
developing more aggressive disease so
when we look at 14 33 ADA in the context
of disease severity when we stratify
patients at baseline so when we measure
14 to three levels at baseline before
they go on a particular therapy we see
that patients who are positive 14 to
three have higher clinical and
serological scores so the image here
when we look at it acta is anti-ccp CRP
is c-reactive protein ESR is the ureter
site sedimentation rate and hack is a
clinical outcome referred to as a health
assessment questionnaire so you can see
that for instance when you look at akba
patients who are positive 14 23 have
significantly higher akpa they have
higher CR Pete compared to the negative
patients they have higher ESR and they
also have significantly higher hack so
at baseline 14 23 identifies identifies
patients who have worst disease so if
you're 14 23 positive you would expect
that they would have more severe disease
when we look at this now and look at
longitudinal data which is reflective of
the image on the right the line graph
the line not graph there we see that
again patients who are positive 14 23
when you look at radiographic outcomes
so how much joint damage do they
actually have within their joints we see
that the rate of radiographic
progression or the burden of
radiographic damage is higher in
patients who are 14 3 positive compared
to 14 3 negative patients so arguably if
you're 14 33 positive you're more likely
to progress and develop more severe
disease
one of the things that's really of
interest for 14 23 in those seronegative
patients so the patients that are 14 23
negative you can see that some patients
do progress right now we've only looked
at fourteen to 380 levels at baseline so
at time zero there are ongoing studies
that will look at 14 23 8 levels over
the five years in those 0 negative
patients to see if some of those through
negative patients convert and actually
become 0 positive 4 14 13 and we feel
that there's value in routine
measurement of 14 23 because you know
when we look at the other markers there
is some evidence that some patients will
Siro convert and become positive so we
do believe that 14 to three as well and
we do have data that suggests this in
small and small cohorts that patients do
have the opportunity or the ability to
serial converter and become positive for
14 23 so for us it would be very
interesting to look at the patients who
were initially seronegative and
especially in those patients that
develop more radiographic progression
over time do they become Sarah Paulson
for 14 23 but the data as it stands
right now today it shows that if you're
positive for 14 through trader at
baseline so x 0 you're more likely to
have more severe disease and more likely
to develop more aggressive disease as
marked by radiographic damage
progression so when we think back to the
in vitro data showing that 14 through
three ADA induces factors that are
intimately linked to both inflammation
and joint damage clearly you know the
clinical biomarker data supports the in
vitro data in that if you're positive or
you have higher levels of 14 23 you're
more likely to have more severe disease
and develop more joint damage so there
is that alignment between the clinical
biomarker data in the in vitro mechanism
of action data that further
substantiates 14 23 as a rational drug
target that should be further
investigated
one of the next things that we've looked
at is 14 two threes relationship to
therapeutic outcomes so if you remember
from the mechanism of action slide we
saw that 14 23 ADA was able to induce
factors like tnf-alpha il-1 we also have
data showing that it induces il-6 and so
there you know actually and I don't have
this data presented there but we have
data in dose-dependent in a
dose-dependent fashion showing that when
you stimulate 14 ourselves with 14 23 in
a dose-dependent fashion as you have or
increase the concentration of 14 23 you
increase the output of these different
ligands so higher levels equate with
more induction of these inflammatory
factors so there's a dose-dependent
effect and so when we think of that
clinically that's important because
again do higher levels of 14 23 equate
with different patient outcomes and so
as you can see from this particular
slide here lower levels of 14 23 at
baseline together with a decrease in 14
23 meaning that if you measure 14 23 at
baseline and then 15 weeks following
therapy if the levels decrease
post-treatment that equates or
corresponds with better response to
therapy as determined by disease
activity measurements and we've seen
this now across different classes of
therapy such as d martes so
disease-modifying antirheumatic drugs
like methotrexate as well as with anti
TNF so in the interest of time I'm going
to present data around the anti TNF
today but I'm happy if someone would
like to get in touch with me after the
fact to share data on the D marks as
well so why is there a real impetus in
the field to find markers that can
predict outcomes not unlike cancer
obviously you know you want to find
markers that reflect better patient
outcomes to improve patient outcomes but
also to resile reduce the economic bird
of the disease because ra is a chronic
disease it's very costly and payers now
are really tightening things up wanting
to have better outcome data and at the
end of the day what they're really you
know kind of pushing folks to do is to
align any markers or start any drugs
with markers that can afford you know
the patient as well as the payers to
identify patients who are more likely to
respond right at the outset as opposed
to not having something like this where
arguably you just follow standard of
care they really want to align any new
therapies with the markers so that you
can not unlike what happens with in
breast cancer if you have marker X
arguably you treat the patient with drug
X or if you have marker why you treat
you know the patient with a different
different drugs so the classic Herceptin
her to you know situation is something
that's of real importance in the field
of rheumatology really to improve
patient outcomes and reduce the economic
burden of the disease so this data
represents data in patients who were
treated with an anti-tnf therapy so
these are our eight patients that were
treated with various anti-tnf so we're
not looking at a specific molecule
within that class we're looking at all
molecules within that class and this is
data represented on 74 patients before I
go into the clinical data if you just
remember from one of the earlier slides
we had shown that 14 33 ada connection
boost tnf-alpha we've now looked at
tnf-alpha and we see that tnf-alpha can
also induce 14 to 380 and ourselves and
other people are now in the literature
have shown that there's an interplay
between 14 23 and tnf-alpha in that
tnf-alpha get induced 1433 data so based
on this interplay we think this
rationalizes why in some patients we
might see that when you treat a patient
with tnf-alpha that arguably the levels
of 14 23 decrease
because of this particular nexus that
exists within cells so moving over now
from the rt-pcr data to the information
presented on the upper right hand side
we see that when patients are treated
with an anti-tnf that the 14 3 3 levels
are modifiable so at baseline when you
measure baseline levels and look at 15
weeks out at the 14 to three levels we
saw that there was a significant
difference between 14 to 380 levels at
baseline and those at 15 weeks out and
so with that if you look at the change
in 1433 what we saw when you begin to
look at patients in terms of response if
you look at those patients who achieve a
good you'll our response meaning that
they do well clinically if we look at
the change or the decrease in 14-3 and
equate it with the change in serological
measures in the good you'll our
responders and importantly the change in
ESR CRP and dass are used as routine
measurements to monitor patient outcomes
we see that a decrease in 14 23 equates
or strongly correlates with a decrease
in ESR CRP and Dassen when you look at
the r square or the r value for instance
just looking at the change in ESR with
the change in 14 23 you know you can be
confident that that's a real phenomenon
when you see a p-value like that now if
we move over to so essentially sorry
before I move over to the left hand side
it the change or the decrease in 14 23
Idzik waiting with better clinical
outcomes now when we move over to the
information on the left-hand lower
left-hand side this is data generated
from a ROC curve so receiver operating
characteristic curve when you look at
patients who do well so achieve a good
you'll our response compared to those
patients that do not achieve a good
you'll our response and you look at
baseline measurements of 14 through
three what we see is lower levels
reflect or lower levels are in sorry
lower levels of 14 to three equate with
a better
uncle outcome so when you look for
instance that a cut-off of less than
point for one you're five times more
likely to do better or to achieve a good
you'll our response then patients who
have levels above that particular 14 to
three level so lower levels equate with
better clinical outcomes so you can see
that if a patient has less than point 27
nanograms per mil there are eight times
more likely to have a good you'll our
response so if we think of that
mechanistically as the levels of 14 23
ada increase in serum it's going to be
driving up more factors and even though
the patient may be having an appreciable
benefit to that particular therapy
because 14 23 exists in the background
at high levels is going to be continuing
stimulating cells to induce these
different factors and that might explain
in part why the patients don't do as
well clinically so lower levels to begin
with and a post-treatment decrease
equate with a higher likelihood of a
clinical response and we've regressed
this out through modeling and that data
holds true so lower levels with the
post-treatment decrease predicts who's
going to do better now looking at the 14
23 autoantibodies one of the things that
is exciting trust and further validates
the importance of developing a
therapeutic to 14 23 ada is that what we
see is that the auto antibodies
complement for 23 in diagnosis but that
when you're positive for 14 23
autoantibodies you have more favorable
outcomes so they appear to operate as
endogenous therapeutics that protect the
patient so the view there is that if you
are 14 23 autoantibody positive and you
have higher levels that you do better
clinically so this is data that we've
presented recently at one of the
European actually at you are just
recently in Madrid and what we see here
is the
that when you look at 14 23 autoantibody
levels and if you look at the scatter
dot plots what you see is that the 14th
century auto antibodies are
significantly higher in early disease
compared to establish disease where the
median and interquartile range look
comparable you know to healthy
individuals and patients with away so
for whatever reason the auto antibodies
seem to be preferentially expressed in
early disease and that when the disease
progresses there's only a subset of
patients that are able to sustain this
particular auto antibody response so if
you look at established disease there
are a subset of patients that have
levels that fall within the range of the
earlier a patient set and so when we
look at this this is quite exciting
because because of the fact that you
know these autoantibodies are very high
in early disease does it create an
opportunity to capture that forty
percent of patients that may you know be
seronegative for the other markers such
as anti-ccp NRF and if so you know does
it complement 14 through 3 as well in
terms of diagnosing patients so when we
look at the receiver operator
characteristic curves not surprisingly
we see that you know the 14 23
autoantibodies are highly specific for
early re compared to healthy individuals
Oh way as well as all control so an area
under the curve close to 1 represents a
very good and perfect test so you know
you can see from the data there that 14
these autoantibodies with the area are
approaching you know as close to 1 and
so they're highly significant as denoted
by the p-value there and it's worth
noting that this is data based on 550
patients so again it's not a small
cohort and you know we've now expanded
the earlier are a study looking at north
of 250 you know patients and this data
holds true and larger cohorts now I
think what's interesting just quickly
going back is if you look at established
disease in those patients that are able
to sustain the art antibody response so
the patients in gold there when you look
at the patients who have high levels and
who would be positive for the auto
antibodies what happens to their patient
outcomes and so when we look at you know
a subset of these patients you get when
we look at patients who are positive
only for the protein so the 14th III
protein as denoted by the 15 patients
there versus patients that are only
positive for the auto antibody 35
patients so ie you know they're only
positive for one of the markers either
the protein so they're not negative
they're negative for the auto antibodies
and the autoantibody positive patients
are negative further protein when you
look at their joint damage scores that
you're for near five you see that the
patients who are positive for the
protein not positive for the auto
antibodies have hired joint damage
scores at year foreign and year five
then those patients that are only
positive for the auto antibodies and so
it means that patients who are positive
for the auto antibodies seem to be doing
better clinically and we have data
around this as well with response to
therapy that if you're positive for the
protein and negative for our sorry if
you're negative for the protein and
positive for the auto antibodies that
you actually do better clinically as
well so we're now embarking on studies
to look at you know this relationship in
a broader sense to look at its
complementarity in terms of diagnosing
patients as well as prognosticating
patients so can we use these two markers
really to subset patients into different
risk categories and can this can these
two markers also assists us in
delineating or predicting therapeutic
outcomes so this brings me and I'm
almost close to the last slide here but
priorities for RX are as i was saying to
focus on commercialization of the 14 23
protein test so it is marketed in the US
we've also received Health Canada
and European approval so we're now
embarking on distribution agreements to
make 14 to 38 of the protein test
broadly accessible we're also focusing
on developing IBD tests for the other
three biomarkers and I'd say that we're
around the corner with the ante 14 23
assing having something that would be
ready you know or close to go to market
the other two assays to sit anti-state
assays are markers that are slowly
coming up and we expect by i would say
q2 of 2014 to have those markers
available for clinical use and one of
our other priorities not surprisingly is
to advance a therapeutic program so
we've all so one of the things that
we're currently doing there is screening
models to identify a relevant model that
would actually express 14th between the
auto antibodies in a comparable way to
patients and so we've already started to
look at the collagen-induced arthritis
model and we see that upon induction
that the 14th III protein is actually
present and we can measure it and that
the animals also within 10 to 12 days
start to develop an auto antibody
response to the protein and so the view
there is to use the markers to identify
which animals to treat and how to treat
the animals so for instance if you're
mounting a good response on your own to
the protein you might consider dosing
that animal differently than an animal
that arguably has the protein but does
not develop a robust autoantibody
response so we feel that the markers
together with a therapeutic program
represent one of the first personalized
medicine strategies for rheumatoid
arthritis so here are some of the
abstracts that we've presented on 14 23
and you can access that information also
through the objects website and with
that I thank you for your time and if
you require any additional information
please feel free to contact me I've
provided my email address for you and I
thank you for your time and that's the
end of my presentation thank you I'll
take any questions
time anyone may have so I thank you
again so i just received a question from
Pierre bhutan the question is what is
the animal model you quoted Ferrari are
there any more yes ah so there's there's
a number of animal models that are
commonly used so there's the
collagen-induced arthritis model there
is the KX bien model there is the AIA
model which is a rat model there is the
CIA model which stands for the collagen
antibody induced arthritic model and if
you'd like to reach out to me I do have
a review paper that cites different
animal models within the field that are
commonly used and I'd be happy to
forward you a link or the actual paper
itself
any other questions at this time
you